welcome to this video playing WGME ruler
from Johnny this is gives a lot of fish
stick if you're from Germany you maybe
know her she's um the I don't know about
30 time German blitz champion for four
female players she really knows her no
sir blitz chess not a bad play at all
she has some years ago she beat what's
that take a look fine really i if I'm
not mistaken mistaken in in Frankfurt in
one of those rapid events so she's
dangerous let's see um she played the
the champ offski attack uh-huh
interesting with cream b3 him ok let's
do that the somewhat unusual thing is
that i have the night only for so f 3 is
possible or she does take them that's a
very unique position so interesting
interesting play so to have 60 2d6 let's
drop to f6 ya b3 as a move that concerns
me ok I don't think that Bishop f5 is
such a great idea it loses lots of time
and I don't think it helps me that much
ok so di do I get in before probably not
rook to e8 she will move the rook
let's do something aggressive try to
take and play e5 yep just opening up the
position for them for the bishops of
course the drawback is that white gets
the center oh I was thinking she would
take with the pawn aha now this is
interesting it at XP five I was still
only expecting the pawn capture long
term however this is of course very
risky for why yeah it's giving me
fantastic bishops be 595 bishop f3 but I
can retreat on IG for there's ecigs okay
then let's go there
are interesting didn't think about that
one yeah do I want to play Bishop e7 I
don't know mmm not sure I wasn't really
sure about that this this was the
alternative and it looks quite quite
decent giving me some some good
positions for my pieces so no she is not
threatening to take material 32 hangs
okay but what about this can I go to d3
that looks quite nice
Bishop c6 bc6 is excellent of course and
yeah I can grab this just not so sure
how great it is on 93 okay let's take
that come on yeah this is nuts not that
easy Bishop c6 there's always the
potential for D 5 D 5 coming I do it can
I give up be high if I don't know if I
should ok let's just do that i can drop
back to the seven it's not not fatal of
this thing maybe I get an f6 yep
yeah it's not very active this kind of
position f6 is e 6 mm yeah I know it
doesn't look great but I don't know what
to do actually
amazing trying to go for whoop dat
should be six stuff remarkable how this
went down hill so so relatively quickly
still kind of hanging on but it looks
really really bad is f6 a move manager
and now I would know we'll play it even
if if it's not so great or anything i
have to somehow get rid of this night
he's six I will take the night taking as
well time morning check yep what is
fairly active check check at least I
caught up check somewhat in time check
and this zone blunders blonde nurse
Rooke check check check check yeah
there's absolutely no way to play for a
win just lutely no way check
I don't tell me I'm losing this game as
would be the shabby bad really I'm just
about in time check-in draw oh yeah that
was that was really tricky after I won
this pawn I knew that it wasn't easy i
really knew that so have a let's have a
look night at four check TT exam i mean
this is this is this is good for white
what can you do i mean it's just by pure
counting like sabana but why it is so
active so active i probably have to play
it differently somehow yeah i mean even
here this is this is questionable to be
honest i didn't see that 94 idea if i
would have seen that i would have played
bishop d6 trying to keep control here
and this is certainly quite ok for
blackie i mean black should be better
here with the two bishops but this is
also strong the 94 idea didn't i didn't
take that into account and here and this
is this really really was problem why it
has a huge initiative yeah I know my
moves look like without any plan but
there is nothing I cannot really do
anything here I'm just shuffling around
and she completely yeah he's in control
that was a mistake allowing f6 which I
found which I found ah Bishop age five
is good oh I didn't see that move
yeah this is typically strong computer
suggestion yeah white cannot take check
and this does this sign it moves yet it
prepares the capture only five with the
win very nice young black is clearly
better him yeah but that's very
difficult to find but Bishop Bishop f5
is doable I was glad that here the worst
is over but this is even this is even a
problem because why it's huge initiative
remarkable she was a relatively good
defense i think it was act at least d 6
i'm still just along the brink of defeat
him check check yep check he drank check
check check check here it's a draw i was
brief and concerned i miscounted the
pitcher but it is ending in a draw yeah
that was interesting i white had to use
in huge initiative for the pawn it
wasn't clear fair door with the with the
initial extra pawn or you think okay a
pawn is a bond but it's not easy at all
yeah interesting game thanks for
watching